what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest craziest chapter of
dragon ball super
i said last time that i've gotten hooked
on the latest arc
and this chapter keeps the hype going so
make sure to stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing these monthly
dragon ball super reviews
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do is channel the god of
destruction within and destroy that like
button until it's blue if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit the naughty gang bell or you will
miss future dragon ball super videos and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop
feel free to check out our dragon ball
virgin podcast where my friend who never
watched dragon ball and i
are covering the entire dragon ball
story from beginning to end
we started with the og dragon ball
series and we just got to dragon ball
super last week which i'm very psyched
about
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all the
title of this chapter is the heater's
plan
and this space crime family is
definitely full of surprises you gotta
give them
credit where credit's due but more on
that in a bit first we continue with
whis training goku remember whis is
training goku and mastered ultra
instinct
while beerus is training vegeta and
destruction we start out with some
comedy as whis
asks goku what's the decisive difference
between him and the angels
and we all know you can't expect goku to
get these things right but he tries and
guesses that it's the halo thingy as
i've been re-watching the entire series
from the beginning
for the dragon ball version podcast i
really gotten a newfound appreciation
for the comedic moments like this one
i absolutely just love goku as a
character and personality rather than
just
as an epic fighter whis doesn't just
correct him but knocks him with his
staff
first before telling him that the
difference is that angels are always in
the ultra instinct state
while goku is equating ultra instinct to
a transformation
wii says that while his heart is calm
his body should move on its own no
matter what form he's in
i love this focus on tranquility and a
seeming oneness with the universe that
ultra instinct is associated with and i
also love the idea of goku being able to
use it in his normal form
however i did worry that we wouldn't get
to see the cool transformation again
and as if anticipating my concern whis
says the full transformation will still
be used
as a last resort when a battle demands
for him to surpass his limits
thus in theory even in his normal form
goku will be able to use
ultra instinct and this will conserve
stamina
and mean he won't have to deal with a
time limit unless the opponent
is out of this world again i really do
love that principle
of getting stronger in your base form
and not having to change into a super
saiyan or whatever to reach a certain
level of power
whis then gets vegeta's attention too
and it's noteworthy that he's appeared
to move on from a pebble to a large
boulder for his destruction training
whis gives both of them a somewhat
obvious but also powerful quote
when he says while training your rival
should be yourselves from the previous
day
work hard to grow stronger than your
past selves end quote for both of them
this seems obvious that they're getting
stronger by training day after day
but whis feels the need to remind them
because he sensed granola's power
when goku asks if it's an enemy whis
even says he's not sure if it's an enemy
exactly so props to him here
that he can sense so much either way it
seems he doesn't want his students to
get discouraged
if they get wrecked by this new force
and to just focus on being stronger than
their past selves
and although it may be obvious advice
it's rarely followed which is a shame
because it's arguably the best way to
improve and move towards your goal
in just about any endeavor you can think
of it's funny vegeta
insults the nugget of wisdom but you
know he's the first to forget it
whenever he gets bested by an opponent
in battle
with the heaters oil and maki are
actually going on a mission to gather
info on the saiyans
they will talk to master zuno someone
who knows
everyone's weakness gas has an
interesting conversation with alec
gas wonders if all this trouble is
necessary for granola
but alec is a good antagonist precisely
because he is so careful
since granola is supposedly the
mightiest warrior now
he wants to be safe gas wishes he could
have fought with him
as the strongest member of their family
here alec actually shocked me
first he says just in case the worst
case scenario happened he didn't want to
risk losing gas
but more than that he goes on to say
that his moment to fight will come
and that he can surpass frieza himself
the fact that he said
ken rather than just surpasses suggests
he has the potential to surpass frieza
rather than that he already surpasses
frieza but either way
that's quite the power considering what
we know about frieza with that kind of
power and their scheming
this family is definitely worthy of
going up against our protagonists
for elek his main goal is nothing less
than that the heaters
will become the supreme force in the
universe it's an interesting motive
and one i prefer to someone just wanting
to destroy the entire universe for fun
when maki and oil arrive to zuno's
planet
we get a pretty funny situation where
zuno won't answer any questions without
the offering of a kiss from maki
you got zuno over here picking his nose
while maki is horrified and angered by
the idea and wants oil to deliver the
kiss
instead but she's told that zuno will
not accept kisses from portly men
the bizarre scenario definitely got me
laughing and i enjoy
seeing the personalities of the
antagonists being fleshed out here too
zuno gets his kiss and since he likes
feisty women he decides to answer
10 questions we jump back to goku's
training and he is doing very well in
his base form he's avoiding whis staff
with his eyes closed notably he stops
the staff with a finger at one point and
then balances a top of it on a single
foot
you know that's gotta take calmness of
heart and it's impressive to see goku
advancing so much down this path
even whis can't help but smile at his
progress vegeta for his part is
destroying multiple things falling from
a waterfall including a giant log
he appears to go a bit overboard and
angers beerus
but it's equally impressive progress and
it's nice to see vegeta and beerus's
completely different dynamic contrast at
the goku and whisus
not surprisingly we find out that goku's
weakness
was none other than chi chi another
hilarious
if predictable moment after being told
by chichi that goku hasn't been
home for months maki asks if she can
summon him since she's heard goku isn't
one to defy her commands
and as soon as chichi mentions money
running dry
they got her maki offers her money in
exchange for goku helping her with a job
the money situation is also a
long-running joke that i appreciate in
dragon ball
chichi is the practical one who is
always thinking about it
while it's the furthest thing from
goku's mind as he always wants to train
for free
it's never a matter of money with him
which is another detail i tend to love
about shonen protagonists in general
chichi gets bulma to help her call goku
and vegeta back
maki presents it so that granola seems
like a villain they have to defeat and
chichi tells goku that they're gonna pay
him to beat this guy
and goku needs to do it in order to
bring home the bacon now and then
once they find out that this new villain
is supposed to be the strongest in the
universe they realize it's probably the
guy the oracle fish was talking about
and both goku and vegeta can't wait to
go and test their skills
in a real fight after so long you gotta
love vegeta's line too when he says and
i quote
none may claim the title of the
universe's strongest
without my say end quote so of course
goku and vegeta are hyped
as are we for this inevitable battle
back on earth maki continues to stress
how bad this dude is and how they'll not
only make money
but save the lives of so many poor
helpless people
this seems to be for bulma's benefit at
this point because obviously chichi was
already hooked
by the offer of money but bulma has all
the money in the world so she's a
different story
there's a great moment that i really
liked before goku and vegeta leave
beerus's planet
beerus gives vegeta an earring that is a
symbol for those who can use destruction
as i keep mentioning vegeta is getting
closer and closer to a god of
destruction every chapter at this point
but what really amused me was how beerus
added that vegeta should prove that a
god of destruction signature move
is stronger than angel techniques whis
responds competitively himself by
putting his mark on goku's uniform as
well
it's so entertaining watching these two
get competitive like this
and it serves to add even more meaning
to the upcoming fight vegeta does in
fact put the earring on and i gotta say
vegeta's addition is definitely cooler
than goku's and i hope he keeps the
earring from here on out
despite all the rivalries going on whis
tells them that excess
confidence may be their doom again
warning them to take this
seriously and to be cautious these guys
definitely have a history of letting
their power
go to their heads so i hope they
actually heed the advice
this time but with goku vegeta you never
know
in the meantime maki finds a dragon
radar at bulma's
and plans to use it to find cereal's
balls and we get another funny moment
where chichi gets a shine as she insists
that she doesn't want any fancy space
money since it's useless on earth
after being told they'll pay in gold she
lights up again
in a great mood my god i'm so glad that
we get to keep experiencing these
awesome characters through the super
series
when the two finally get to earth it's
nice to see chichi and bulma tell goku
and vegeta to be careful
vegeta's short spartan-like response of
and i quote i know
end quote has gotta be my favorite on
the space ride to cereal our boys notice
the beautiful ship
that even has a pool in it and a gourmet
chef that can cook up anything of course
vegeta is the one to notice that oddly
enough
they have a pretty luxurious spaceship
for a tribe whose planet is being
ravaged by some great destroyer
but maki is quick on her feet and
explains that of course they'd prepare
a special ship for their saviors vegeta
is not too concerned anyways since he
can train and in his mind
of course the prince of saiyans deserves
the best so he drops the matter while
goku never even picked it up since he's
too busy thinking about the food
goku eats vegeta trains in a space pool
and maki calls granola
letting him know that two of frieza's
assassins are coming there to serial
of course she's lying and the two
assassins are goku and vegeta themselves
the finishing touch is when maki adds
that these two goons
are members of the saiyan tribe that
drove syrians to extinction
granola eats right out of her hands here
he is shocked and he's all the more
motivated to get revenge now the way the
heaters built up these narratives for
these two sides is impressive although
both sides are arguably good they've set
it up so granola is very unlikely to
talk it out
at least from the start i can imagine
him flying at them in a rage
and being totally non-responsive to any
questions because 50 years ago
saiyans destroyed his tribe and now two
are returning to the same planet again
it's the perfect thing to say to him a
guy whose reason for being is revenge
and who sees everything through that
lens i am very excited for this upcoming
battle and to see what happens with the
heaters too
right now i think they're making great
antagonists and we'll see if they can
keep it up
i definitely enjoyed this chapter but i
have no doubt that the next one will be
more hype as the battle actually gets
underway
and we see the fruits of goku and
vegeta's training
and that is it for this video thank you
so much for watching as always let me
know what you thought of this chapter
and what you're most excited to see
in the upcoming chapters if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit the noti gang bell or you will miss
future dragon ball super videos
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out our
dragon ball virgin podcast where my
friend who never watched dragon ball
and i are covering the entire dragon
ball story from beginning to end
we started with the og dragon ball
series and we just got to dragon ball
super
last week which i'm very psyched about
link to that is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patrons of
legend the ones acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself alpha sigma red haired
raven and av
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrada pate heffa dr cortman the
toasted chi
bang emperor otaku spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist and
yuno and our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kozadski
cricket xp
rethuan dei aura very gucci alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia ted no ted
i sparky 65 jessica lafond metal mama
cory mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
and soul rise slice and dice thank you
all so much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime outdoor link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel
by clicking that blue join button next
to subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you